okay moving on with the proceedings I
would like to look at the next article
which is a suspension period in minakami
if we are gonna do this for another
beautiful year I would like to make out
with 5 T 5 T people 50 people Ilana
- and I have to know about
I mean deal communication is dope on the
long term front I would like to bring up
issue with the state of Maryland I think
I'd like to move there you just want to
up and moved middle of nowhere in
Maryland well I'm from there so my whole
family will be there my brother's a
dense is also and we've always wanted to
start our own practice the tooth factory
and there's lots of great schools that
school so what like cars drive around
them slower and it's safer to walk no
schools for the children that I father
to attend
Oh discussing this your I don't really
remember reviewing this for my notes
well I guess while looking at this
year's points
I looked ahead at next year and the year
after that is this about the rom-coms
cuz i'll watch one every weekend you
know and I'll just rip a bong and laugh
really sincerely and I'll learn to love
them no it's just it I want to buy a
house I'm living on Zillow how does not
even that expensive in there and I want
to have kids and I want to get married I
think you know I'm only 27
what am i a child bride you know I don't
know that I never won and I just
definitely don't want it right now I
could commit to a kid when I'm like 43
Lincoln I just figured out that I want
to go back to school and focus on my
witness I'm on a New York City timeline
do you ever think you change her mind
at this point I can't move on this
I have no counter IIE
I have no counter
well these points are non-negotiable for
me
[Music]
ah watch it oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
we were short caterers and Abbey's never
really been talented with the tray so
I'm so sorry actually Abbey's an
up-and-coming artist and my personal
guest not a caterer
yes yes so I'm actually catering but I
am mm also a guest okay AB we're gonna
need you to start loading some dirties
into a van so the liars aren't cool no
III know I don't think they're cool
either you know what I have to go find
some canapés clear my mind
Donna I can get you canapes I can't pig
I have access to all don't worry about
it she can get her own canapes it's not
that bad I don't even like this dress
it's too yellow I am so sorry this is
not how this was supposed to go down I
was so excited to be here tonight as a
guest with all these cool art people I
mean I'm actually an artist too I'm just
not like a real one you might not want
to say that what it's smart to have a
flexible service job so that you can
make art I waited tables for years and I
spilled on lots of people in fact half
my pieces are inspired by people I've
spilled on oh well what are your pieces
like you might know my work I'm toy
Harris
Oh your new toy Paris holy dude
your toy Harris you're some third floor
it took us years of protesting but we're
here I cannot believe you knew it I can
so you want to just you know I can't
believe I smoked I spilled onto a
herrings I spill on poor hair okay I am
getting diseases or unseen good night
[Music]